[Music]
cartoons were a huge part of most of our
childhoods and we all have our favorites
but we bet you never noticed these weird
things in some of your favorite cartoons
stick around to see the shocking reason
why cartoon characters actually wear
white gloves don't forget to subscribe
to our channel and give this video a
huge thumbs up now join us as we take a
look at the ten strange things you never
noticed about cartoons Goofy and Pluto
this strange thing went viral after fans
realized something pretty weird
happening in the Disney universe we'll
talk more about how Disney characters
are actually connected but the fact
about these two is mind-blowing Goofy
and Pluto are both actually dogs if you
think about it goofy is Mickey's best
friend and Pluto is Mickey's pet but
goofy is allowed to wear clothes walks
like a human speaks English and
basically doesn't act like a dog at all
Pluto on the other hand is a typical
Disney dog who barks and does everything
a dog would do did you ever notice that
these two completely different dog
species actually exist in the same
Disney Universe
there are many fan theories as to why
goofy is allowed to act like a human
while Pluto is just a dog when reddit
user states that Pluto knows he's a dog
while goofy just thinks he's a person
which seems to fit the Disney mantra
that you can do anything you set your
mind to another user argues that Goofy
and Pluto aren't actually the same
species at all but they both fall into
the same class shanem louse key from
overthinking it created this awesome
chart of Disney dogness that shows just
how many different Disney dog characters
there are maybe we really are
overthinking this one if you have an
answer or a theory about this let us
know in the comments Cartman is Archie
Bunker have you ever wondered if
Cartman's character from South Park was
actually inspired by any one Eric
Cartman is definitely unique and you'll
never find a cartoon character that's as
hilarious as the sassy guy well it turns
out there might be Cartman was actually
based on Archie Bunker from all in the
family a fictional character whose
attitude and strong mind is just as
entertaining and controversial as
Cartman is in a 2014 podcast Norman Lear
the guy who plays Archie Bunker revealed
his character was actually an
inspiration for Cartman his sarcastic
character was an inspiration
from what the creators thought Archie
would look like as a kid Norman himself
had to negotiate with CBS when it came
to airing his raunchy and controversial
lines but it seems like Eric Cartman was
able to continue the tradition the dream
came true for the creators of the show
when Norman Lear actually became a
consultant for the two South Park
episodes in season seven the first is
called canceled and it is the show's
100th episode and the second is I'm a
little bit country how strange is it
that Cartman who is a young version of
Archie Bunker was co-directed by the
actual Archie Bunker one thing's for
sure both of these characters are unique
in their own way and we hope they never
change inappropriate jokes
the strangest thing you can find in
cartoons are the innuendos and subtle
jokes you've probably missed as a kid
have you noticed how many inappropriate
jokes are said by some of your favorite
cartoon characters it seems strange that
a show for kids we even go this far but
you wouldn't believe how many shows have
way too many hidden innuendos from Hey
Arnold and the odd try my sausage sign
pointing to grandpa Phil too many in new
windows we have seen in Sponge Bob
Squarepants cartoons like to squeeze in
a few adult jokes that aren't meant for
kids there are hardly any shows that
have managed to escape these subtle
hints and the truth is you won't get
them until you're older even ratatouille
made an inappropriate joke about getting
too familiar with vegetables we bet
there are a couple of dirty jokes out
there you never even noticed when you
watched your favorite cartoons some of
these made our jaw drop even this buzz
lightyear scene after he sees Jesse for
the first time raises a couple of
eyebrows we recommend watching all your
favorite cartoons and Disney movies and
see how many subtle jokes you can find
you'd be surprised by how many you
didn't get as a child and that's
probably a good thing share your
favorite subtle cartoon jokes in the
comments below
The Simpsons predicted the future if
Yuri watched some of the old episodes of
The Simpsons you'll notice that they
have managed to predict the future more
than 10 times they predicted that Donald
Trump would become President of the
United States in an episode called Bart
to the Future the episode shows that
Hillary Clinton is the first female
president of the United States but also
states that Donald Trump was the
president before her and he managed to
bankrupt the country in 2017 Donald
Trump did officially become the
President of the United States but the
Simpsons episode was aired more than 15
years before but it's not the only
prediction the show has made
to make one of these strangest
predictions that actually came true was
in the episode called politically inept
with Homer Simpson which aired in 2013
the Simpsons show a headline that Europe
put grease on eBay well that didn't
actually happen
the 2015 Greek financial crisis was the
main news topic for quite a few weeks
and who can forget about the 1994
episode that talks about the horse meat
scandal in Springfield Elementary School
The Simpsons predicted it would happen
20 years before the actual horse meat
scandal made international news either
the writers of The Simpsons are psychic
or this is one just hugely strange
coincidence
spongebob squarepants we've seen some
pretty weird cartoons out there and
SpongeBob SquarePants is not an
exception we all know the show was
created by marine biologists who
actually cleverly introduced the
under-the-sea world to children we also
know that the show is full of
inappropriate jokes and innuendos that
you'd never expect in a children's show
but of course this makes it much more
fun to watch for adults as many of the
kids don't even understand what's going
on but here's another strange thing
you've never noticed about the show it
was confirmed that Stephen Hillenburg
actually based the main characters on
seven deadly sins and the Spongebob fan
broke it down for us
Patrick is supposed to be sloth
spongebob is lust Squidward is wrath mr.
Krabs is greed plankton is Envy sandy is
pride and Gary is gluttony when you
think about the characters personalities
this actually makes a lot of sense
spongebob loves everyone around him
Patrick is just simply lazy Squidward is
full of hatred mr. Krabs loves money
plankton is jealous of Krusty Krab
success Gary always has to be fed and
sandy takes pride in who she is and
where she comes from for a show full of
innuendos and excessively weird plot
lines SpongeBob SquarePants is actually
a pretty clever cartoon with a lot more
beneath the surface unaired Looney tune
episodes here's something we bet you
didn't know about Looney Tunes the
popular animated series features some of
the most recognizable cartoon characters
on the planet but there are a few
strange things about this Warner
Brothers show we all know cartoon humour
can sometimes go too far but did you
know that Warner Brothers has 11 Looney
Tunes episodes that had to be pulled off
the air they're known as censored 11 and
they are mostly made in the early 30s to
the mid 40s they were pulled off air for
having racially sensitive content that
would feed into a major controversy
saying that we all know there are plenty
of Looney Tunes episodes out there that
still raise a few eyebrows and are just
simply uncomfortable to watch here's
another thing that many seem to remember
from earlier Looney Tunes episodes
according to a few people the series
used to be spelled with two O's instead
of a U but it turned out that this was
never in fact true it's now considered
the Mandela effect which is explained as
a phosphate that's actually remembered
by a large group of people did you ever
imagine that Looney Tunes could have
this many controversial episodes cartoon
characters have three or four fingers
let's talk about cartoon fingers have
you ever noticed that many of the
cartoon characters have very simplified
designs and you can rarely find a
character with five fingers Mickey Mouse
Homer Simpsons SpongeBob SquarePants
characters from the Looney Tunes The
Flintstones and many more all just have
four fingers
strange right well there are a few
explanations behind this according to
cartoon animators it just makes the
character easier to draw and animate
most animators tend to struggle with
drawing hands which is precisely why
these cartoon characters only have a
thumb and three fingers Emmy
award-winning animator Jeff Marsh said
that all animators simplify their
animations to save time and claims that
dropping just one finger makes a huge
difference this dates way back to the
time where people had to draw characters
by hand it saved them time and most
importantly it saved money many of the
modern-day Disney characters and
princesses do have five fingers but we
bet you can find many with this
animation shortcut does your favorite
cartoon character have three four or
five fingers cartoons that have
characters with five fingers include
king of the hill clerks and peanuts
while it's pretty strange to see a
character with only three or four
fingers we bet you never even noticed it
when you watched your favorite cartoons
mojo jojo's voice sugar spice and
everything nice these were the
ingredients chosen to create the perfect
little girls remember the Powerpuff
Girls the popular series lasted from
1998 to 2005
and had an avid fan base that was
completely smitten over these three
quirky characters what's not to love
about the Powerpuff Girls they're cute
they're funny and most importantly they
have superpowers that can save the world
but that's not the thing that's strange
about this cartoon have you ever paid
any attention to mojo JoJo's voice as
the villain Mojo Jojo wasn't exactly the
most popular character ever but that
shouldn't mean he didn't play the
essential part to the show but this
super villain has a connection to
another iconic scary character remember
the screen franchise ghost face was one
of these scariest things ever but
believe it or not he actually has a
connection with Mojo Jojo if you ever
thought that Mojo Jojo and ghost face
from scream sound the same you're
actually right the Powerpuff Girls
villain is played by Roger Jackson who
is also the guy behind ghost face in
every single scream series
so before Mojo Jojo even existed he
played one of these scariest villains
ever isn't that the strangest connection
between the two iconic characters ever
and even though mojo JoJo's face is
definitely not as scary as ghost faces
we can see how these two could actually
click my little pony
the popularity of My Little Pony battles
even the biggest fans of the show
this series attracts a huge fanbase of
the middle-aged male population but
that's not even the weirdest thing about
it
my little pony went through a couple of
strange development phases before it
became the series you know today there
are so many strange things surrounding
the show we bet you never knew the
ponies actually first came out as a
ten-inch doll in 1981 and the franchise
had more than one television series one
of the weirdest things about my little
pony
is baby ponies all 10 of the original
MLP characters had babies and they
actually named them after themselves
so Lickety splits baby would be named
baby look at these splits nothing wrong
here right but does that mean if the
adult baby you look at me split had a
baby the baby would be called baby baby
you look at he split the whole My Little
Pony conception is just bizarre and the
original baby ponies were actually born
from their mother's reflection so the
ponies can be immaculately conceived the
minor details of the show definitely
make it a lot more bizarre but it's
precisely what we love about the show in
1989 the drink and wet ponies also wore
actual diapers we promise that the more
you look into this show the more odd
things you'll find out that you never
noticed before wearing gloves this
strange thing only belongs to all Disney
characters have you ever wondered what
they have in common they're all wearing
gloves while Mouse ears are one of the
most iconic Disney accessories white
gloves are becoming the next best thing
have you noticed just how many
characters wear gloves you can find them
on Mickey Mouse Bugs Bunny Woody
Woodpecker Tom from Tom and Jerry and
more gloves were created because it made
an animators life easier especially when
all characters had to be hand-drawn Walt
Disney has another explanation why
Mickey was one of the first cartoon
characters for the gloves he says he
didn't want to show Mickey as a typical
Mouse and the white gloves make him more
human he also explained that Five
Fingers looked too much on Mickey which
is why they had to stick to four but
there's a bit more to this fact the
white gloves were actually a standard
part of blackface performers and these
cartoon characters are shoutouts to the
controversy back in the day the American
entertainment industry consisted of
these controversial performers that
would paint their faces black to do
sketches and sing songs all wearing
white gloves white gloves on Disney
characters particularly Mickey Mouse
have been therefore marked as racially
offensive but it seems like that Disney
is continuing this animation tradition
and that's it for ten strange things you
never noticed about cartoons for more
videos like this one check out ten
innocent cartoons banned in other
countries see you next time
[Music]